Healthcare is a basic human right,
not a privilege.
We have thousands of healthcare workers unemployed,
800 medical doctors still unemployed,
and thousands more professional nurses,
physios, dietitians,
and the list goes on.
But stick around.
Want you to meet a few people.
I'm a doctor in South Africa.
Of course, we're still unemployed.
I'm a professional nurse in South Africa.
Of course, we are the backbone of the healthcare system,
but we are unemployed.
I'm a physiotherapist in South Africa.
Of course, there's 300+ of us unemployed.
I'm a doctor in South Africa.
I studied for six years
and there's three years of training,
but I still can't serve the people in South Africa.
I'm a South African Community service doctor.
Of course, I'll be having an unemployed next year.
As it stands,
there's one doctor for every
3,000 patients in South Africa
and one nurse for every 218 patients.
I'm a public patient
and of course,
I've waited seven hours to get help.
I am a doctor in South Africa.
Of course, we wanna serve our people.
I am a patient in public.
Of course, I had an emergency
but only saw doctor five hours later.
Let's give our people the quality
health care they deserve.
I'm a patient in public
and I deserve better.
I deserve better.
Our patients deserve better.
We're no longer gonna wait for change.
We're gonna create the change.